[Musique]
ça va
tu es calme aujourd'hui
tu as envie de dormir
on va jouer un peu quand même
allez c'est parti
un peu
tu te souviens du terrain
[Musique]
tu te souviens on fait du foot
le projet on se de légende c'est un pari
de réunir des enfants autistes et des
enfants non autistes au sein d'une
équipe de foot et de leur permettre de
s'entraîner tous les mercredis matin et
d'apprendre à se connaître
[Musique]
aujourd'hui en France les demandes sont
très importantes en matière d'activité
physique et les offres sont encore très
peu présentes pour les personnes avec
autisme
[Musique]
ce qui est assez inédit dans ce projet
c'est qu'on a autant d'enfants autistes
que d'enfants non autistes on est
vraiment dans un objectif d'inclusion
c'est-à-dire qu'on a le groupe des 16
enfants chaque jeu va être proposé pour
les 16 enfants
l'un des objectifs aussi c'est qu'il
joue avec les
U9 de l'association du Paris
Saint-Germain à l'occasion d'un tournoi
à la fin de l'année
[Musique]
j'ai quelques appréhensions sur comment
ça va se passer avec des joueurs une
heure du paris-saint-lama qui sont dans
la compétition qui qui excelle à ce
niveau là ça peut être compliqué
ce que j'espère qui va se passer c'est
que les enfants vont s'ouvrir à la
diversité qui vont se dire finalement on
n'est pas obligé de mettre des
étiquettes les enfants sont différents
mais on est tous différents et se
rendent compte aussi ils ont plein de
passions communes
[Musique]
alors on regarde par ici on va se
présenter rapidement d'accord donc moi
je m'appelle Baïla donc je suis
éducateur à la fondation du PSG moi je
m'appelle Audrey
[Musique]
comment tu t'appelles
ma grande
tu viens par là
moi je sais que tu t'appelles blanche
mais elle elle sait pas comment tu
t'appelles
et on a mon prénom c'est Baila et toi
comment tu t'appelles
Léonard
c'est ça
ok en tout cas il s'appelle Léonard
d'accord
on va commencer tout de suite sur les
sur les petits jeux d'accord je vous
demande surtout d'être concentré d'être
à l'écoute et d'essayer de faire ce
qu'on vous demande ça va jusque-là tout
va bien Émile
très bien alors on va aller sur le jeu
c'est parti allez
[Musique]
personne disons une maladie mais dans
leur tête
c'est des gens qui réagissent autrement
que nous et qui travaille pas peut-être
de la même façon que nous c'est le
mental
ils ont pas trop de mental des fois ils
regardent un peu en l'air ils peuvent
regarder par terre on entend peu très
bien on a fait une grimace et ça va
rester scotché sur toi quand on a des
petits trucs comme ça par exemple il y a
un de mes tontons il est autiste il est
quand même autiste grave quand même il
est bonne autiste
[Musique]
et tu vas essayer de mettre le chasuble
avec toi on va mettre celui-là tiens on
va mettre tu peux le mettre tout seul
d'accord alors tiens je te le donne je
te laisse
ça va tu vas bien
[Musique]
ok alors je vais t'aider pour le mettre
dans le trou du milieu
voilà et les deux trous sur les côtés
c'est pour les bras voilà c'est beau en
bleu comme ça OK
bah il a
viens jouer ton prénom Léonard tu dois
le dire à haute voix d'accord
très bien tu commences à parler hop là
comment tu t'appelles
très bien allez vas-y
[Musique]
la première fois c'est clair que je suis
sur le quai pour pour être totalement
franc je suis attentif à tout ce qui se
passe j'essaye d'avoir un oeil un peu
partout parce que forcément il y a des
comportements que je découvre à ce
moment-là
merci
[Musique]
le ballon là
le premier jour j'ai quelques craintes
quelques appréhensions je me pose des
questions sur comment je dois réagir un
peu avec l'enfant si je peux le toucher
si je peux pas
comment je dois parler il faut pas que
je parle trop fort ou alors si ou
quelques questions en fait que je me
pose
[Musique]
avec moi viens me le donner à moi
voilà très bien comment je m'appelle
[Musique]
Baila d'accord voilà tu peux dire bah là
aussi si tu veux
[Musique]
certains enfants d'énormes difficultés
de par leur troubles autistiques mais
aussi au niveau moteur on n'a pas les
enfants les plus simples sur le sur le
programme
globalement on est plutôt sur des
enfants non verbaux ou peu verbaux ce
qui est plutôt intéressant dans le sens
où c'est des enfants qui sont assez peu
inclus en général
non Léonard alors
c'est bien on l'a fait avec la main
maintenant on va le faire avec le pied
d'accord avec le pied voilà
ce qui me saute aux yeux c'est surtout
certains enfants qui restent un petit
peu en retrait qui ont un petit peu peur
[Musique]
allez ouais encore encore ça doit aller
vite vite
[Musique]
13 allez tiens voilà
14 15 16 17
17 17 17 17
voilà
encore ami
on va dire que les deux équipes ont
gagné non mais pourquoi j'ai pas compté
parce que vous faisiez des passes entre
eux c'est pas l'objectif il joue avec
tout le monde
bonjour
tu trouves qu'ils sont finalement très
différentes toi ou pas tellement
différents
un peu plus différent et finalement ils
sont pas si différents
très différents très différents pas
tellement parce que ce sont aussi des
humains en fait on connaît pas leur
habitude d'accord
et aussi à jouer au foot de jouer avec
les autistes apprendre à communiquer
avec les autistes et leur apprendre à
jouer au foot et aussi ils prennent du
plaisir et moi aussi consentant de bien
donc
ils sont un peu plus normal est-ce que
tu es triste quand on t'insulte ou
tonton maltraite non plutôt colère
plutôt colère
est-ce que tu acceptes la contradiction
je sais même pas ce que ça je joue avec
des filles dans la cour toujours souvent
rarement ou jamais rarement jamais
jamais
[Musique]
ma mission ça va être de m'assurer que
bien sûr les enfants neurotypiques sont
heureux et joyeux qui y trouve leur
compte je les interviews au début je les
interviewerai à la fin et je vais
essayer d'apprécier justement les
bénéfices à la fois sur eux sur leur
relation à l'autre et sur leur relation
dans le groupe peut-être que dans 6 mois
ses enfants sauront jouer avec les
filles peut-être qu'ils trouveront aussi
que c'est simple de jouer avec
l'ensemble de la cour est-ce que tu te
bats dans la
couronne
les émotions avant c'était beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
et maintenant d'accord et maintenant
c'est rarement rarement rarement
rarement bravo je tiens mes promesses
c'est difficile ça c'est dur
j'ai peur de décevoir mes parents
souvent
au revoir
s'occuper de plus fragile que soi ça va
être se positionner en guide ou se
positionner en personne ressources ils
vont pouvoir en parler en famille donc
le regard des parents va être très
positif et ça renforce aussi l'estime de
soi et quand on est de mieux dans sa
peau on va être mieux dans le groupe
[Musique]
merci à vous allez vite
allez
tu as bien compris
[Musique]
intelligent porteur de handicap il a été
diagnostiqué autiste à l'âge de 9 ans
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Émile il est suivi en
hôpital de jour donc ça ressemble plus à
une école que un hôpital
donc il y va tous les jours de 9h à 16h
le quotidien des milles c'est
un quotidien un peu ritualisé il faut
pas trop de temps mort parce que
rapidement il va s'ennuyer et c'est dès
qu'il s'ennuie parce qu'il a pu la
structure et qui sait pas ce qui après
alors là il perd un peu ses repères et
ça devient beaucoup plus difficile
c'est quoi ça
c'est le maillot de foot
il peut pas faire de sport Émile en
temps normal parce que en fait soit
c'est cloisonné et à ce moment-là c'est
que des enfants neuroatypiques comme
Émile et pour l'instant on en a pas
trouvé
tu veux qu'elle est un personnage
c'était dans un stade avec que des
enfants ordinaires et à ce moment là
faut convaincre le directeur du stade
les coachs sportifs c'est tout un
parcours du combattant et du coup il a
jamais pu faire d'activités scolaires à
cause de ça mais par contre il a besoin
de se dépenser c'est un enfant quoi
c'est un enfant comme un autre donc oui
c'est bien pour lui et il est aussi
épanoui dans ce sport il prend plaisir à
le faire donc oui c'est c'est un vrai
plus
on voit bien qu'il s'amuse énormément
avec son frère avec les amis de son
frère avec les enfants de nos amis
il est épanoui donc pour nous
tout ce qui était inclusif c'est
richesse c'est
c'est des progrès beaucoup plus rapides
donc oui c'est un projet pour moi qui
est juste parfait pour les enfants comme
lui
[Musique]
après
attention c'est parti allez
il y en a
oui très bien
la bienvenue
en marchant on va essayer de faire en
arrière d'accord donc tout le monde
regarde Théo tout le monde regarde comme
ça on se tourne on se tourne allez c'est
parti
[Musique]
et voilà
d'accord doucement voilà on s'écarte
[Musique]
est prêt c'est parti allez on regarde et
on recule on rec
ule
où ça c'est bien
voilà allez recule recule je veux voir
d'abord tout le monde tourner par là-bas
tout le monde tournait pas là-bas allez
on avance
voilà très bien blanche très bien très
bien
super reste face à moi regarde-moi voilà
allez viens maintenant il va falloir
courir le plus vite possible et prêt
[Musique]
ok stop on revient par là on se
rapproche
[Musique]
droit
ici vous allez devoir vous faire des
passes à la main donc là par exemple je
la donne à Gabriel tu la prends et je
compte un Gabriel tu fais la passe à
n'importe qui vas-y qui tu veux
voilà il t'a fait la passe ça fait deux
Moussa tu fais la passe à qui tu veux
avec la main d'accord
[Musique]
Léonard
pas mal
[Musique]
c'est comportement sont déstabilisant
les premières séances parce qu'on
connaît pas les profils on connaît pas
les enfants on n'a pas du tout cette
approche de l'autisme sur le terrain
est-ce qu'on y va est-ce qu'on laisse à
quel moment du coup on le ramène toutes
ces petites questions qui qui se posent
à ton écoute
Léonard
on va lancer le ballon
tu vas lancer le ballon
à l'un de tes copains
la difficulté avec Léonard va être
principalement la communication Léonard
parle anglais avec sa maman et français
avec son papa donc c'est à nous
entraîneur encore une fois superviseur
d'adapter notre moyen de communication
pour essayer de susciter sa motivation
il y en a
comme comme
merci Clément
3 2 1 top allez
pourquoi pas très bien ça
va
ne pas écouter
tous les exos il est très malin sur ça
allez champion
c'est toi comme tout le monde
[Musique]
j'ai dit ah j'ai pas dit top
ah dommage juste à côté
[Musique]
Léonard ça va être à toi
certains comportements m'ont marqué je
pense à Ewen surtout qui s'est très très
vite adapté au programme
[Musique]
comme ils sont gentils avec moi
je suis gentil avec eux et je les aide
en quelque sorte je leur montre le
chemin je dis suis-moi aimé suis-moi
blanche suis-moi Léonard
et il me suivent
[Musique]
dans la cour de récré un jour il y avait
quelqu'un qui l'embêtait je dis tu vas
prévenir la maîtresse il me dit mais je
veux pas aller prévenir les maîtresse il
va se faire gronder bah oui mais voilà
ça c'est vraiment purement un gentil
quoi
la particularité des Wayne c'est qu'il a
déjà eu une expérience dans son
entourage proche avec le handicap et ça
aussi on le sait plus on a eu de contact
avec des personnes en situation de
handicap plus on va avoir de facilité à
rentrer en contact avec eux le handicap
n'est plus associé à une vision
stéréotypée en fait ils ont en tête des
personnes peut-être le cousin l'oncle le
frère la sœur il pour eux handicap ça
veut dire quelque chose et donc du coup
souvent ils ont un peu moins peur aussi
d'aller vers les autres et c'est
beaucoup plus simple
[Musique]
allez on y va vous me suivez
allez on y va
[Musique]
allez allez
on le fait bien parce qu'après on va le
faire en courant
allez jusqu'au fesses oui encore
tu fais que ta voiture tu viens allez
c'est parti tous ensemble
tu vas être fatigué
je me dis très très compliqué parce que
son profil ne correspond pas du tout
un projet sportif il a pas d'intérêt
pour le foot
[Musique]
essayez surtout on a du mal à l'intégrer
on parle d'un peu plus loin avec des
rames ou clairement il a du mal à se
concentrer plus de plus d'une minute
quoi
vous inquiétez pas on va on va le
récupérer après
au niveau de sa concentration
d'accord ça va être des petits temps
c'est ça
il faut un peu le l'encourager
ces expériences avec le ballon il a pu
déjà jouer un petit peu avec un ballon
jamais ok il prend pas forcément de
plaisir pour l'instant avec le ballon ok
donc c'est ça l'objectif après si c'est
pas possible non mais c'est possible
avec tous les enfants tout est possible
on va aller jouer avec les enfants
[Musique]
bien joué va chercher ta mère je suis
ton but
dommage
tu as vu comment il a réagiaire
[Musique]
je voulais marquer tu vois et là il est
frustré
est-ce que tu penses qu'on peut essayer
parce que Moussa il veut essayer de au
goal
[Musique]
allez c'est parti
on y va
allez bravo Moussa
[Musique]
oui
Moussa on va dire que c'est peut-être la
crème de la crème c'est quelqu'un de
très extraverti donc quand même qui est
très ouverte très souriant de base qui
clairement à des difficultés pour
s'exprimer mais qu'on prend tout à fait
ce qu'on lui demande
je pense que ça lui fait énormément de
bien d'être aujourd'hui présent sur ce
projet et nous le fait de l'avoir c'est
vraiment un régal de l'avoir mais chaque
mercredi
[Musique]
le début moi je crois pas je dis il a
rien quand ils m'ont dit j'ai dit non il
a rien il va parler mais je vois que ça
ça continue ça parle pas ça parle pas
c'était difficile
moi c'était difficile à accepter mais il
y a pas de choix à la fin j'ai compris
[Musique]
on est en atelier cuisine on va faire le
mug cake au chocolat vous savez bien
pour lui parce que moi ça fait une
activité quoi c'est quand même
après moi je veux pas le gérer même là
c'est difficile à gérer un peu tu fais
du sport moi ça va la apaiser parce
qu'il a beaucoup d'énergie Moussa il
dépense pas trop
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va accueillir les
U9 de l'association BG donc je compte
sur vous pour faire en sorte que tout se
passe bien
[Musique]
votre prénom
par semaine dans un cadre déjà bien
défini bien bien stricte de leur
approche elle est de d'aller le plus
loin possible dans dans le football de
gravir tous les échelons du du club
l'objectif je vous préviens d'avance
c'est ce n'est pas la compétition
d'accord on est là avant tout pour
s'amuser pour s'entraider donc c'est
surtout ça qu'on va essayer de faire
aujourd'hui ça va pour vous jusque là
nickel
on y va tranquillement
[Musique]
allez voilà allez viens
avec les deux
[Musique]
on va se faire un mâcontre
pour l'instant on va juste taper dans la
main donc on fait le parcours on revient
au tape dans la main et le suivant
démarre cette fois-ci c'est une course
top allez 10 minutes et bien joué
allez vas-y on fera comme si on avait
pas vu quand je vois les U9 avec notre
équipe c'est vraiment deux mondes qui se
rencontrent
je me dis que ça va être compliqué de
les faire l'ensemble
[Musique]
est désormais terminée qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé de la séance que vous
avez pris du plaisir
c'était drôle ouais c'était bien
[Musique]
vous avez vu c'est pas facile pour tout
le monde
c'est bien d'avoir conscience de ça de
savoir en tout cas ça c'est bien c'est
une bonne chose et moi je veux vraiment
vous féliciter pour pour ce que vous
avez fait aujourd'hui merci à vous je
pense que vous pouvez tous vous
applaudir parce que vous avez été top
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
dans les bars
ici
et Emile ils sont ouverts
[Musique]
tu as plus envie de faire les choses que
je rigole plus avec Moussa mais aussi je
rigole avec Juan et je trouve ça je
trouve ça bien parce que aussi parce que
à l'école des fois il pourrait y aller
personne qui reste pas avec eux parce
qu'ils ont ils ont des handicaps moi je
trouve que justement au contraire faut
pas rester avec eux pour les pour les
gens dans la vie c'est
je sais pas comment expliquer mais je
trouve que eux aussi je sens qui qui
sont fiers d'être avec nous parce qu'on
les aide
[Musique]
-moi
bonjour
allez Moussa
on va regarder
[Musique]
bravo OK
ok tu reviens en courant
[Musique]
il est en voiture
fais le tour voilà allez reviens reviens
reviens Juan
je garde
[Rires]
une petite pause c'est pas possible on
peut pas jouer comme ça
allez tu vas venir avec moi Roanne on va
aller on va aller marcher un petit peu
tous les deux
on court on court un peu tous les deux
allez on court allez on va courir un peu
tous les deux
on fait un petit retour un petit peu de
l'entraînement du jour comment vous
l'avez
comment vous l'avez ressenti aujourd'hui
on essaie de développer un peu plus
c'est quoi bien
bien très bien après c'est très très
bien
[Musique]
raison est-ce qu'on prenait pas j'ai
rien fait de mal
et comment tu vas réagis quand tu es
tombé
vous pouvez pas venir à la violence et
comment dire que c'est ça
et comment on peut
c'est pas comme toi donc c'est normal tu
trouves que c'est normal toi
très très très très normal
ils sont pas comme nous
mais c'est aussi pour Juan une manière
de pouvoir jouer avec vous de pouvoir
rigoler en tout cas faut pas hésiter
aussi à nous dire un petit peu votre
ressenti comment vous ressentez la chose
est-ce qu'il y a des difficultés que
vous avez rencontrées pendant la séance
par rapport à ça aucune difficulté aussi
j'ai pas de difficulté
[Musique]
concentration si très réduit tu vois
mais d'habitude échauffement motricité
c'est son temps après on sait que ça ça
descend un petit peu mais là c'était dès
l'arrivée des l'échauffement donc il
faut trouver le pourquoi de cette
attitude peut-être qu'il a mal dormi tu
vois est-ce qu'il a déjeuné ce matin
est-ce que parce que pas dans une
période un petit peu tu vois
d'excitation aussi c'est la semaine
dernière c'était pas du tout
les comportement droit n'a pas rechouté
dans les plots on le reprenait aussi il
était cadré quoi c'est clair que là
aujourd'hui ça a été compliqué ça a été
compliqué
[Musique]
depuis l'année dernière ça deuxième
manière en fait d'équité rapide il a une
séance tous les 15 jours avec c'est une
psychologue en fait je l'ai quitté un
peu en question
[Musique]
à répondre à des consignes parfois il
nourrit l'animal en fait ça l'être dans
les difficultés qu'il a au quotidien
justement dans les interactions sociales
et toi
une heure par semaine le reste du temps
il fait des apprentissages à la maison
il a beaucoup de séances justement avec
des éducateurs avec des professionnels
qui le suivent depuis plusieurs années
déjà
et voilà j'ai quand même remarqué que il
avait effectivement tendance à aller
vers Clément aller le taquiner etc
parfois effectivement il lui arrive
d'être focus sur quelqu'un ou sur
quelque chose et ça peut aussi lui
arriver de passer à autre chose assez
rapidement donc moi je pense que
peut-être que s'il arrive à l'oublier ça
va complètement tout changer
[Musique]
chez les rouges
allez go au revoir
[Musique]
il a toujours besoin de
de s'évader un petit peu mais il reste
dans le groupe
vas-y Léonard allez go
yes
tu me le fais
[Musique]
tu vas bien tu veux venir jouer un petit
peu avec nous tu viens
blanche à la naissance elle a été
dépistée avec une déficience auditive
elle a été appareillée à l'âge de 5 mois
puis ils ont découvert que elle avait
des problèmes de motricité elle était
hypotonique du corps chez Blanche c'est
ça toujours été un sujet la des muscles
qui sont tout tout et donc elle n'arrive
pas à forcément avoir la même force
physique qu'un enfant de ménage elle a
commencé à marcher à l'âge de 3 ans de
mémoire 3 ans elle commençait à marcher
elle a commencé vraiment à bien
maîtriser la marche à l'âge de 4 ans
1 2 3
et plus
[Musique]
parce quelque chose quand elle est dans
l'eau et c'est essentiel pour elle de
d'avoir cette séance hebdomadaire à la
piscine avec avec sa psychomotricienne
et
on sent que on sent que c'est son moment
à elle
blanche elle est elle est bien sous
l'eau parce que au niveau sensoriel
c'est ce qui lui c'est ce qui lui
convient cette bulle où elle se coupe de
tout quand on est sous l'eau quand on
est tout seul ben les sons sont
complètement différents les sensations
sont différentes et elle est beaucoup
sur ce sensoriel là
la joie qu'elle dégage quand elle nage
c'est on arrive on arrive pas souvent la
voir voilà c'est un moment pour elle ou
elle elle est dans son monde
tu vas regarder le dessin animé si elle
était angoissée à l'idée de participer
au projet monstre de légende tous les
mardis soir donc la veille d'aller à
l'entraînement de football elle nous en
parlera en boucle en fait elle ne dirait
je veux pas football je veux pas
football football je veux pas là c'est
quelque chose on prépare les affaires
ensemble du football et puis elle nous
montre ce qu'elle va faire donc elle
tire un grand coup de pied pour montrer
que demain c'est l'activité football et
qu'elle a bien compris que c'était
l'activité football et c'est comme ça
qu'on sait que ça va et puis on a
remarqué quelque chose c'est vraiment
complètement incongru hasardeux
[Musique]
donc il est mort il est pas encore
arrivé
[Musique]
ils ont beaucoup d'énergie
mais parce qu'il réagit à fond tu vois
il va pas aller vers les autres
culture réagi plus il va continuer
et ça tu l'observes chez beaucoup
d'enfants qui recherchent de l'attention
pour Juan il y a rien de mieux qu'un
enfant qui va réagir en fait ou un
adulte
qu'est-ce qu'on avait dit tu sais
qu'est-ce qu'on avait dit
alors pourquoi il fait ça
est-ce que tu penses que c'est peut-être
pour jouer qui veut faire ça d'accord
pendant la séance on va observer
d'accord on va regarder ça marche mais
essaie de ne pas trop réagir ok Clément
c'est pas grave
[Musique]
et toi
je sais pas on va voir avec lui après on
va essayer d'expliquer mais ça va aller
je le vis difficilement où est-ce qu'on
se pose des questions on se dit comme on
peut l'aider à arrêter de se fixer sur
Clément et d'aller voir peut-être
d'autres jeunes d'autres enfants on se
pose aussi la question en fait de ça
poursuit dans le projet
on se laisse un petit peu de temps avant
de pouvoir vraiment donner une décision
on se rend compte que il faut qu'on lui
apporte quelque chose des outils des
repères pour le canaliser parce qu'il a
un profil très intéressant Roanne et un
profil sportif qui est aussi moteur et
leader du groupe
[Musique]
là vous avez observé vos enfants
maintenant depuis quelques semaines qui
participent au projet est-ce que vous
avez observé quelque chose de
particulier en lien avec leur
participation au projet ou pas du tout
ou pas de différence moi maintenant à
table on parle des mines blanches à la
Emile il a fait ça et comme les autres
copains qu'il a le mercredi après-midi
au foot quoi il y a les copains de
l'école les copains du foot habituel je
dirais et les copains maintenant du foot
du mercredi matin mais voilà c'est
vraiment il est content de leur de des
progrès et on a fait ça ensemble et
c'est vraiment encore plus ensemble quoi
souvent les sports adaptés comme il a pu
le faire auparavant sont pas toujours
aussi
encadré intensif
on va composer avec toutes les
difficultés des uns et des autres et on
va souvent être très limité là ils vont
être un peu plus tirés par les uns et
les autres et du coup je pense que voilà
ça le pousse à faire des efforts qu'il
aurait peut-être pas fait ailleurs
d'être en contact avec des enfants qui
n'ont pas forcément de handicap aussi
quoi
pour lui c'est alors la marche un peu
autant des fois mais bon si l'essai
c'est déjà bien tant qu'il se bute pas
trop de l'échec c'est quand même ça
aussi le l'écueil c'est à dire s'ils
rencontrent des chèques et trop de
difficultés il pourrait se décourager
et après s'il y a de la frustration il
peut y avoir peu de colère un peu de
voilà mais si c'est bien mesuré que on
lui demande pas trop j'ai vu tout à
l'heure le tir au but on laisse faire
tranquille il le fait à sa façon ça
passe enfin ça passe pas en l'occurrence
mais
c'est passé mais il est revenu en ce
marrant donc c'était que c'était bien OK
et alors si on
devient ensemble là quel serait une
attente particulière par rapport à la
participation de vos enfants à ce projet
ça pourrait être quoi
en terme de confiance en soi le fait de
d'avoir démarré d'avoir une fin d'avoir
un produit d'avoir quelque chose parce
que la fierté c'est plus pour nous les
parents parce que ce sentiment là je
pense pas que Noé le connaisse
en revanche ce que je peux constater
c'est sa joie il est très joyeux ça lui
plaît énormément de venir ici de jouer
avec ses copains un de nos côtés c'est
un peu plus compliqué où je crois que
tout le monde est un peu au courant que
Clément lui c'est très mal passé je
crois qu'on peut pas dire autrement le
fait qu'il ait pris un coup et un coup
violent il a quand même assez souffert
il a pas fini la séance je l'ai surtout
plus mal vécu c'est que c'était déjà
arrivé donc moi j'ai un vrai problème
face au fait que c'est déjà arrivé et
que ça s'est reproduit donc comment
est-ce que je peux maintenant avoir
confiance
et remettre mon enfant dans une
situation
où il va être un danger on se remet en
question très rapidement à la suite de
cette discussion on se demande est-ce
que Clément va poursuivre le projet ce
qui va être encore motivé à venir ça
serait vraiment un risque aussi pour lui
de perdre confiance en lui de réduire
son estime de soi-même au sein d'un
groupe au sein de ses relations sociales
non ça va c'est bien
dans la maison
tu fais comme tu as envie
alors là j'ai envie de le démonter
et vraiment
se motiver rien peut m'arrêter même deux
adultes M4 il ne peut pas m'arrêter
alors là à part si ils essayent de
m'arrêter de m'arrêter
Clément est un garçon très sensible qui
a eu un petit peu de mal au début en
maternelle en tout cas il était souvent
dans les conflits tout simplement parce
qu'il a par l'État il a eu des problèmes
d'articulation dont il reste des petites
choses mais il arrive maintenant à bien
se faire comprendre et que donc ça a
créé chez lui une voilà une frustration
assez importante petit à petit il a
appris et son principe de toute façon
pour se calmer depuis qu'il est petit
donc c'est les livres voilà les BD
qu'est-ce que vous disiez Kong quand
il n'est pas laissé c'est un enfant
aussi qui a de l'aide en classe il a une
tendine ash une dame qui vient l'aider
pour tout comprendre tout suivre deux
après-midis par semaine donc il est du
côté de ceux qui sont aidés donc ça
pouvait être intéressant pour lui de
voir aussi qu'il pouvait passer du côté
de ce qui est qu'il avait aussi cette
possibilité de son côté et oui
moi je trouve ça très dommage parce que
j'ai discuté avec la maman de Roanne qui
m'a dit qu'il était heureux de venir que
c'était quelque chose donc voilà c'est
quand même
il faut qu'il ait des moments de plaisir
cet enfant pour qu'il a vie doit être
compliqué après c'est évident que je
veux pas que que
clémentiste j'ai pas envie de lui faire
mal
je parle plutôt qui veut faire des liens
d'amitié alors tapant il va jamais
réussir
j'ai encore envie d'y aller que la base
est super et que tout ce que je voudrais
c'est lui un entraînement et c'est pas
de m'attaquer qu'est-ce que j'espère
[Musique]
alors
de ses comportements sur le terrain une
première hypothèse qu'on avait formulé
c'est qu'il a besoin enfin qu'il en
recherche d'attention donc sa manière de
rechercher de l'attention c'est d'avoir
des comportements inadaptés ce qui
fonctionne hyper bien aujourd'hui
Clément c'est c'est le renfortateur de
Roanne c'est sa motivation première
[Musique]
attention à vous
le tableau l'objectif c'est à chaque
début d'entraînement que vous trouviez
votre photo et on la colle d'accord si
on est présent c'est sur le verre
[Musique]
ensuite au suivant
intégrer les enfants autistes on a
travaillé sur des pictogrammes pour
qu'ils aient des visuels à chaque début
d'entraînement
est-ce qu'on fait au début c'est le
ballon la première chose de
l'entraînement ah échauffement ok très
bien voilà la réflexion à travailler sur
ces outils c'est voilà c'est les repères
mais c'est aussi pour mieux gérer le
comportement de Roanne
[Musique]
c'est ça
aujourd'hui tu es avec avec
on est comment aujourd'hui on est un
champion on n'est pas un champion
et c'est quoi être un champion c'est
écouter est-ce que c'est compris
moi je fais du 14 sportif et du 14
spécialisé ça fait maintenant 2 ans que
je m'occupe de Roanne d'abord à la
maison et maintenant en groupe sportif
donc soit la piscine soit dans un
gymnase du coup je vais à travers le
sport et des Roanne dans sa motricité et
aussi dans son comportement
[Musique]
ouais on joue au ballon mais on joue ici
ok ça marche
est-ce que tu as compris
[Musique]
recherche aussi c'est de ce contact
ça va pas
faut arriver à se réguler entre eux
c'est bien là tu as bien joué avec les
copains tu veux tourner ouais
on tourne deux fois parce que
il a joué avec les coupes allez tu
retournes
on va commencer l'échauffement vous avez
mis tous les petites grammes sur le
tableau donc vous savez ce qu'on va
faire aujourd'hui d'accord on va essayer
de surtout de retrouver les repères
qu'on avait avant les vacances donc on
va démarrer tranquillement comme
d'habitude sur des allers-retours allez
c'est parti tranquillement c'est parti
tout doucement voilà Gabriel c'est bien
blanche voilà super encore bravo voilà
on va faire à la même chose c'est parti
allez tout doucement
voilà très bien
allez c'est bien
c'est bien Léonard
ok vas-y elle est où ta photo
alors vas-y tu l'apprends tu arrives
avec les gants
super bravo
et tous les mercredis matin tu fais ça
pour dire que tu es là OK
tu as vu ta photo allez c'est parti dans
ton équipe on repart regardez bien 13
minutes pour la motricité d'accord après
ça c'est terminé d'accord après ça ça
sonne terminé et on va prendre la petite
pause d'accord ouais on est bon 13
minutes nickel on est prêt
pas besoin d'aller trop vite allez run
mais les pieds dans les cerceaux jaunes
et ensuite tu vas faire le slalom
voilà très bien
tu m'as oublié le slalom juste ici
Roanne
alors encore une minute
et on va le donner et on va le donner
[Musique]
c'est pas la bonne mine
tu viens
[Musique]
déjà je le vois il est content il a le
sourire après il s'échappe souvent de la
séance c'est ça
ouais très bien
ok top
aujourd'hui j'ai eu un Roanne beaucoup
plus concentré en tout cas beaucoup plus
de temps que d'habitude il arrive à très
vite se focaliser en fait sur la séance
donc ça aussi c'est vraiment bien je
trouve est-ce qu'il y a des petites
astuces des petits outils qui pourraient
faire en sorte que ça se passe encore
mieux moi le point que je pourrais vous
appuyer c'est de mettre plutôt l'accent
sur le positif plutôt que sur ce qui
fait de de mauvais de que Louis en fait
il soit plus fort que le nom tu vois
quand il y a un comportement que vous
estimez une adapté vaut mieux le mettre
à part lui expliquer ce qu'il a fait
inadapté sans mettre un point énorme
dessus et quand il fait bien quelque
chose là vous pouvez faire la fête
vraiment lui dire c'est trop bien Roanne
tu as fait vraiment un truc trop bien et
tout lui il a un bon retour il
l'enregistre et il comprend pourquoi
vous êtes heureux et à côté de ça comme
les comportements qui sont négatifs bah
vous les reprenez pas trop au final vous
mettez pas une attention hyper forte
dessus et ben il va me diriger son
curseur il va se diriger vers ah bah je
vais faire des trucs bien et les trucs
moins bien je vais peut-être un petit
peu les mettre de côté
[Musique]
attention numéro 3
un autre one
[Musique]
à la barre
attention on verra
mais dire numéro 4 allez vas-y allez
vas-y
là ici maintenant vas-y prends le ballon
encore
[Musique]
allez vas-y ouais super
bravo
alors là je me dis qu'on a fait un gros
travail parce que on partait de très
loin avec des rames et de le voir
arriver jusqu'à ce niveau de
concentration d'implication parce qu'on
peut parler de concentration mais on
voit voilà qu'il est parfois encore dans
les nuages mais il est dans les nuages
avec le ballon en train de réaliser
l'exercice qu'on lui demande et donc
c'est un peu une double facette qui là
en lui en même temps et je trouve ça
assez exceptionnel pour te dire de 1 il
reste sur le terrain de deux il fait
l'exercice parfaitement et en plus il
prend du plaisir donc je me dis que
c'est juste parfait l'objectif il est il
est atteint à 100%
voilà très bien allez vas-y ouais bien
joué bravo
et de rien de rien de rien de rien allez
vas-y
c'est quoi qui te fait rigoler
[Musique]
alors on y va on y va on y va voilà très
bien bravo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
super très bien très bien
je vois qu'il se passe quelque chose
dans dans la cohésion à ce moment-là je
me dis que c'est super on ressent une
grande fierté c'est qu'il y a un premier
premier bout de chemin une première
étape qui qui accomplit qui est
l'acceptation de l'autre de l'entraide
et surtout que ce soit naturel
allez très bien
je pense que les enfants ont mis en
place des solutions pour rentrer en
communication avec d'autres enfants qui
ont des réactions différentes de celles
qui connaissent ils ont mis en place des
réponses tactiles corporelles et je
pense que ça c'est quelque chose qui
ferait peut-être pas à l'école et qu'ils
apprennent dans cette inclusion dans le
foot et ça va certainement leur servir
par exemple dans la cour ou dans la vie
allez vas-y je vais te prendre le ballon
je vais te prendre le ballon
[Musique]
j'en apprends beaucoup
du comportement des des jeunes parce que
ça reste un reflet de notre société mais
aussi tout simplement de la vie et là ça
en apprend beaucoup sur notre capacité à
être à être patient à comprendre qu'on a
qu'on a tous des différences qu'on a pas
tous les mêmes facilités
[Musique]
avec les autistes et maintenant on y
arrive là c'est comme si on est dans un
rôle d'entraîneur pour les autistes
celui qui est devant toi
non toi faut que tu touches les Bleus
d'accord
[Musique]
comme comme le E de Noé
tu finis le bas voilà Noé c'est
quelqu'un de très attachant de très
ouvert il est très câlin allez on se
concentre allez je vais t'aider c'est un
jeune verbal il sait très bien
s'exprimer il comprend très bien ce
qu'on lui dit il a un petit souci
décoller c'est à dire qu'il a tendance à
répéter les mots qu'on va lui dire c'est
par exemple si on lui dit bonjour Noé il
va répéter bonjour Noé là on va se
concentrer sur la lettre C c'est comme
c'est comme Cohen
et c'est qui Cohen
o et Cohen
allez
il a du mal à faire un choix entre le 8
ou le nom ou quand on lui pose une
question il a tendance à répéter la
question le d'y répondre directement
c'est là que l'activité foot elle
devient intéressante parce que dans le
foot il faut faire certains choix de
temps en temps soit porter le ballon
tout seul soit faire une passe soit
tirer et je pense que ça peut être
bénéfique pour nous
[Musique]
voici
je vois Noé évoluer je le vois bien
progresser ça va dans le bon sens en
tout cas
tu veux ta maman
ou le foot
avant que cet événement se produise de
manière régulière je connais pas de
temps pour lui dans la semaine en tout
cas je fais un super long trajet pour
venir mais j'y tiens et je prends une
journée off tous les mercredis je me
libère je suis je me consacre
entièrement à lui et c'est comme ça que
j'en profite en fait
[Musique]
merci de nous recevoir chez vous cette
fois-ci là qui sont venus à Clamart déjà
participé à notre entraînement donc
aujourd'hui on est content d'être parmi
vous et de pouvoir participer au début
de votre entraînement
[Musique]
pour nos enfants il y a un gros décalage
mais on voit une complicité qui est en
train de naître entre les deux groupes
et ça c'est super
rapide
[Musique]
en tout cas je suis content là il y
avait de la qualité je suis content très
bien les deux groupes ok ok
ok les enfants
on va commencer
ok alors juste moi je m'appelle Sylvia
je suis avec Théo on participe tous les
deux au projet 11 de légende et là
l'idée on va prendre un petit temps pour
discuter ensemble de ce qu'est l'autisme
on vous a mis une feuille vous pouvez
écrire dessus vous pouvez dessiner vous
faites ce que vous voulez l'important
est que sur cette feuille il y a un
petit peu votre perception de l'autisme
votre vision à vous
[Musique]
riels
mais c'est quoi nous du coup
[Musique]
besoin d'amis aussi
on s'entend plus à force de parler
[Musique]
j'aime bien rester avec eux parce qu'il
rigole beaucoup quoi au moins j'aide des
gens à progresser
[Musique]
ça m'a apporté de connaître un peu plus
la langue du cap de l'autisme par
exemple là si je vois dans la rue en
autiste j'ai pas l'air d'être méchant
quoi alors que peut-être qu'avant
j'aurais déjà il est bizarre mais
maintenant
je dis plus ça je peux plus dire ça
[Musique]
allez ouais vite on t'attend c'est le
dernier
[Musique]
tu viens ici 2 secondes juste deux
petites minutes
[Musique]
on se tait maintenant
alors déjà est-ce que vous avez vu qu'il
y a une nouvelle personne aujourd'hui
s'appelle Gabriel d'accord donc elle
vient d'arriver dans le programme du 11
de légende et elle sera avec nous
jusqu'à la fin d'accord là on va essayer
de courir vite vite vite 3 2 rester
survenue
[Musique]
de retard sur les enfants neurotypiques
donc c'est bien
[Musique]
joué ça
encore ouais allez on est parti allez
[Musique]
si je dois comparer les deux Roanne du
début du projet de la fin de projet je
dirais que c'est quasiment deux garçons
différents avec une capacité de
concentration qui est pour moi a explosé
[Musique]
me voir grandit je le vois heureux et au
début on ne voyait pas forcément et ça
c'est une belle évolution
[Musique]
il y a des vrais progrès qui ont été qui
ont été faits par Clément notamment et
je pense qu'au fil du temps il s'est
rendu compte qu'il fallait vraiment
adapter son comportement qu'il fallait
interagir de manière différente
on se rend compte que Clément il va déjà
moins répondre immédiatement il va avoir
comme réflexe prendre un peu de distance
calmer un peu sa colère qui doit
sûrement avoir à l'intérieur il a su
faire un effort et retourner vers lui
[Musique]
tu viens avec moi
voilà
[Musique]
tu viens
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
la motivation chez berame on peut la
percevoir comme irrégulière c'est à dire
qu'on peut avoir des phases ou parfois
des reins peut être content de venir en
séance et puis d'autres phases ou berame
n'a pas envie de venir à la séance et ça
ça peut être dû à différents facteurs
est-ce que il a été prévenu de la séance
le matin même est-ce que il ne s'est pas
passé quelque chose un imprévu avant
d'arriver à l'entraînement
il y a eu aussi des ruptures nous dans
l'accompagnement il y a eu les vacances
scolaires il y a eu Marie qui
l'accompagne au quotidien qui n'a pas pu
être là sur de mercredi de suite je
crois que aujourd'hui Behram il nous
montre aussi qu'il a peut-être envie
d'arrêter et
il le dit pas que ces mots mais il le
dit je pense avec son comportement et je
crois que il est possible que là on
prenne le temps de dire stop l'aventure
pour lui peut-être elle s'arrête
aujourd'hui
avec du recul je pense que c'est une
bonne une bonne chose parce qu'il
n'était pas du tout dans dans le projet
il avait beaucoup plus de difficultés
c'est pas du tout l'objectif il faut que
le faut que l'enfant il ait envie d'être
là c'est quand même le principal
[Musique]
bonjour Annie bonjour
alors je vais te poser des questions et
tu te souviens on répond par toujours
souvent rarement jamais on y va est-ce
que toi tu as peur de décevoir tes
parents
rarement et tes copains
jamais je respecte les règles de l'école
dis-moi dans la vie toi tu te fixes des
buts non les arrête à la récré tu joues
avec les filles
oui des fois oui souvent souvent
j'aime bien jouer souvent alors toi
qu'est-ce que tu as pensé déjà de cette
expérience de légende bah c'était bien
au début je me disais ce sera du foot
quoi mais finalement c'était pas que ça
c'était c'était mieux on a joué avec des
autistes et de 10 maintenant ils savent
mieux ils vont mieux je trouve pas comme
ça ils peuvent ils peuvent s'habituer
aux autres personnes les restes avec eux
et se faire des amis et moi aussi mais
moi ça m'a appris à me mettre un peu
plus doux parce qu'avant j'allais fort
c'est des enfants qui ont 9 ans ils sont
en CM2 c'est la journée on apprend à
réfléchir et moi j'ai eu l'impression
que j'ai légendes ça a été un terrain
pour apprendre à réfléchir
trouver des stratagèmes pour vivre en
équipe avec des enfants différents et
j'ai trouvé extraordinaire quand on leur
pose à tous la question
pour toi c'est quoi l'autisme question
incroyablement complexe pour la majorité
des adultes et bien ils ont su répondre
avec leur cœur des choses extrêmement
subtiles tu trouves que les autistes ils
sont très différentes toi ou pas
tellement différents parce qu'on a
beaucoup de choses communs enfin moi
j'aime pas qu'on montrait dans les
oreilles par exemple n'aiment pas et toi
alors si on te demandait de dire ce que
c'était l'autisme tu dirais quoi
c'est des enfants handicapés qui sont
pas forcément pareil tous ils sont un
peu plus timides et ils ont peut-être
envie d'être seul aussi
[Musique]
isolée et
allume ça je sais pas j'ai pas encore
trouvé au départ c'est une bande
d'enfants qui ont envie de jouer au foot
ils ont envie d'échanger ils savent pas
très bien ce qu'ils attendent et peu à
peu on sent qu'ils vont être
responsables de ces enfants autistes ils
se sentent une responsabilité de groupe
ce qui est quand même un degré très
élevé dans les compétences sociaux
émotionnelles je pense qu'il faut du
temps pour changer les regards sur la
différence là on est sur une expérience
qui a duré 6 mois probablement qu'on a
planté des petites graines dans l'esprit
de ses enfants je pense que ça doit être
consolidé mais on leur a montré
que c'était positif aussi d'être avec
des enfants différents de soi qu'on
pouvait vivre plein de choses très
positives et très belle
[Musique]
encore encore
ouais grave
[Musique]
ça va mon chat
il a du mal à dire ton prénom
Gabriel qui est arrivé en cours de
projet je la trouve très avenantes très
à l'aise envers les enfants autistes
elle communique simplement en leur
parlant même si il lui répond pas elle
elle va reparler rééchanger avec les
moyens qu'elle connaît sans réticence
j'ai l'impression qu'elle voudrait
certainement se faire une idée de ce que
c'est l'autisme peut-être plus que ce
que c'est le foot
[Musique]
on va l'enlever on va l'enlever
on essaie
c'est bon est-ce que ça va ça te gratte
pas
ça va mieux
[Musique]
allez on écoute donc la semaine
prochaine on va faire un match avec les
U9 du PSG on va faire 5 équipes d'accord
ça va être un petit tournoi 55 d'accord
super
[Musique]
concernant les consignes des matchs vous
allez jouer normalement donc il y a des
mini buts donc il y aura pas de gardien
5 contre 5 d'accord sur le terrain et la
chose la plus importante dans un premier
temps écoutez bien les tacles sont
interdits d'accord je suis un peu assez
tique sur comment ça va se passer parce
que en effet la partie jouer c'est
quelque chose qu'on a eu du mal à mettre
en place
[Musique]
n'est pas peur
il est pas Léonard les blancs
[Musique]
jouer doucement avec lui
quand les tournois démarre on voit que
ça fonctionne pas forcément on voit que
qu'on est exactement dans ce dont on
avait pensé donc tout de suite on met
une deuxième solution en place
sur Moussa ici une fois que le ballon
est passé tant pis en fait c'est zone là
c'est interdit à tout le monde comme ça
c'est plus clair tout le monde interdit
à tout le monde sauf Moussa et Émile
si vous marquez Clément si vous marquez
d'ici ça fait un point si vous faites la
passe à Roanne et que Rohan il marque ça
fait trois points
tu viens dans la zone
[Musique]
oui ok
hélas
tout devient super fluide et on se
retrouve dans une super ambiance avec
des supporters priori qui sont venus
supporter certains jeunes on s'y
attendait pas
[Musique]
je repense un peu au début où il se
connaissait pas les jeunes et du coup
arriver au tournoi où là ça se prend
dans les bras ça se sourit ça rigole
ensemble je me dis il y a du chemin qui
a été fait quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça permet de travailler aussi pour tout
le monde plusieurs objectifs pour les
petits neufs de l'association de
dédramatiser une défaite de souffler un
petit peu d'être un peu en dehors de la
compétition et de leurs objectifs de
joueurs professionnels voilà ça les fait
ça leur fait voir aussi qu'il y a
d'autres choses en dehors qui a des
enfants qui sont en difficulté et qui
ont d'autres besoins et pour nous pour
nos enfants ça les a valorisés le fait
de jouer avec les petits neufs de
l'association il y avait du monde ça a
permis de partager pas mal de choses
autour du football de mettre en réussite
nos enfants autistes qui étaient
vraiment primordial le fait qu'il marque
des buts qui se rendent compte qu'ils
ont marqué qu'ils ont fait gagner leur
équipe
[Musique]
de toi
tu fier de toi
[Musique]
moi le premier je m'attendais pas à ce
que ça se passe aussi bien à ce que tout
le monde puisse accepter les consignes
et vraiment ça a été pour moi en tout
cas une réussite totale
de voir tous ces jeunes là très
différents les uns les autres pouvoir
autant s'entendre et autant profiter
ensemble dans vos moments c'est un des
plus beaux moments que j'ai passé enfin
en tant qu'éducateur sur un terrain de
football
[Musique]
regardez bébé
je pense qu'il y a énormément progressé
en ce moment où je l'ai vu la première
fois et maintenant quand je vois sur le
terrain je me demande si c'est le même
Léonard
de kids training moi j'ai vu deux
changements profonds chez Léonard le
premier c'est la concentration et la
deuxième chose c'est le débit de mots
stop
King all the kidia Augustin musique
le fait que en six mois on est plus déjà
voir des progrès c'est très bien c'est
même remarquable mais je pense que pour
nous les parents on voit plus loin on
doit voir plus loin et donc moi mon
espoir c'est que cette initiative se
poursuit dans le temps pas seulement
pour Léonard mais pour pour tous ceux
qui en ont besoin
[Musique]
le mercredi matin il rattrapait pas ça
pour rien au monde
j'ai l'impression que cette expérience
elle va le nourrir tout au long de sa
vie j'espère que ça va l'aider à mieux
appréhender la différence des uns des
autres
[Musique]
comment ça comprendre que en fait quand
les gens font pas exactement ce qui est
attendu c'est pas toujours volontaire
là où je suis surprise c'est la patience
des autres camarades j'ai trouvé que
tous les petits enfants étaient au
rythme des enfants comme Émile et c'est
ça qui m'a bluffé
l'inclusion c'est possible c'est pas
uniquement un mot c'est pas toujours
facile on n'a pas eu des séances très
très simples chaque semaine mais on a
réussi parce que on s'est donné les
moyens de toujours corriger de toujours
essayer de rattraper un petit peu ce qui
avait moins fonctionné
je pense que pas mal de monde était
peut-être un peu sceptique et je pense
qu'on a montré qu'on avait fait quelque
chose de beau qui va pouvoir perdurer
dans le temps et j'espère se développer
à plus grande échelle
bravo
[Musique]
c'est vraiment très bien